hi my name is jorge j prieto I'm a
screenwriter from queens new york i
began writing at the age of 14 when I
was a teenager bullied and harassed beat
up in school I was very shy introverted
quiet and I use writing I say method of
coping with the pain that I was enduring
not only from the bullying but from his
childhood experienced when I was 7 years
old I was raped and molested by an adult
family friend member in 2009 through
2010 I started developing a story based
on my experience a high school drama
about teenagers hurting abusing beating
up each other in high school one of the
characters in the story is an
introverted shy student who's afraid not
only of his past experienced when he was
sexually molested back home as I was but
he is also afraid of his own sexuality
at the present time Shia's card is a
title of the screenplay
and I wrote the story to share a light
on this subject and the subject of
bullying and a student speeding up each
other building up on their teachers
parents who don't understand their
children absent parents single mothers I
lived through that in my story a high
school teacher tries to do the best he
can to instill in his students the
importance of a moral compass he gives
the students an assignment a task which
involves a smooth piece of wood like
this cardboard he tells them to soul
search and to look to every person that
they've heard in the past and to take a
nail and put it right into the piece of
wood until they cover five people they
dead must go back to one of each of this
person they've heard if they can and
remove the nail by showing this person
or each person and act of kindness and
act of true forgiveness and remorse they
must then put the piece of wood away and
bring it back after that that's given
holiday I encourage each of you to do
the same even this is something that's
telling somebody took it off do not
bother you anymore this hurts so try
this exercise and see what is left at
the end when you remove the nails and if
you can tell what's exercise it's all
about
riding has helped me to understand to
overcome to know that it does get better
so that's one of the lessons I've
learned and I'll keep writing GS cars
was my first adult screenplay this past
summer I completed the final seventh
draft of that screenplay and I just hope
to get that one which is my most
personal story optioned or produced not
in the far distance I've rinsed six
other screen place ever since my most
recent one about a girl who lives with
an abusive stepfather and who must stay
there and cope because she needs to care
for her dying mother I will now leave
you with the logline of my screenplay
shared scars by Jorge Jay prieto
a devoted high school teacher tries to
help a repressed confused and scared
male student deal with whether it ain
phul secret but the teacher falls victim
to the student when his own secret is
uncovered by the student this is a story
of fear of overcoming of chaos of
confusion and it's ultimately a story of
a hope we all have stories we all have
scars shared scars thank you for your
time